lay out your bearskin picnic blanket if
you spill something just use the
portable washing machine because it's
episode 40 of Lube drift through the day
with the Verrado electric drift trike an
adult tricycle with an electric motor
that lets you drift on flat surfaces
like asphalt ask for a gift and receive
a non basket there are a variety of
themes including one for gamers your
undead friends and for adventurous types
there's the sure I'll try it on basket
handwrite a card to go with it without
making a mistake thanks to the vibe
right learning pen which vibrates when
you make a spelling error now go ahead
and ring the guitar doorbell a doorbell
that strums the cord of your choice on a
miniature guitar when the door is opened
then take off your shoes and slide into
some robot slippers that make this sound
and sip a beverage from a frosty glass
the personal glass froster chills your
glass in seconds with the help of co2
keeping things cool is the beer blizzard
a convenient reusable ice cube placed at
the bottom of a koozie or used as a
coaster that makes sure your
refreshments stay cold satisfy your
appetite and curiosity by catching a
Golden Goose a simple new kitchen gadget
that uses centrifugal force to scramble
an egg still inside the shell or take a
bite out of some alligator jerky and
build your meal with some cooking block
utensils and then clean it up hands-free
with the I touch list paper towel
dispenser clean your teeth while eating
dessert with chocolate toothpaste from
Theoden and then Pizza chair burger
chair cupcake chair that cost money
chair this giant carrot body pillow
might be necessary to relax on this onyx
sofa made out of carbon fiber and
volcanic lava stone now that you rested
use some physics and this axe to chop
wood created by a finnish designer this
new type of axe makes chopping wood
safer and easier by acting as a lever as
a
close to a traditional axe which acts as
a wedge if you're hungry to do errands
get out the hamburger laundry basket and
teach you're taught to clean before it
can walk with the baby mop because
things might get a little messy when
using your at-home Mouse taxidermy kit
that doesn't include a mouse but does
provide an ethical list of places to
source one keep your power source
connected and your charger cords from
getting damaged with a Python cord
protector and keep your phone from
succumbing to gravity with an astronaut
phone stand all while you bring your
Instagram pics to life with the Instax
printer that instantly prints
pocket-sized photos from your phone onto
film hang up your favorites on your
fridge with the ninja knife magnet like
the pictures you'll take while flying
around on your Scout carbon-fiber
paramotor
that conveniently drops you off at your
own personal $27,000 pirate ship
Playhouse I'd love to go to Castle
Murphy bed but right now I have a lot on
my plate play and as always thanks for
watching
you
you